okay so next up is harris lewis from uc
davis i'm talking about here's the
biogenesis project
short and sweet
okay
so
thanks a lot i wanted to thank
broderick he's not here and the
organizers for
inviting me to to talk
today yesterday was really interesting
for me i'm not a
methods developer i'm a biologist
normal assist
and uh so it's it was really
enlightening yesterday to hear uh many
of your
comments so today
at roderick's request i'm gonna have a
try to do three talks in in one i'll
probably run out of time
uh the three parts are to give you uh a
brief infomercial science-free
infomercial on the earth biogenome
project
because i think the project is going to
provide
you with
infinite infinite amounts of data
to compute and to to to look at
interesting problems
and then i'm going to draw on
why high contiguity assemblies the kinds
of reference genomes that we're
producing in the earth biogenome project
are youth very useful
i'm going to show you
some examples from our own work on
chromosome evolution and then hopefully
i'll get to the last part
and i'll talk about some of the
scientific technical and computational
challenges
that we're going to face in a project of
this scale
so what is the earth biogenome project
earthquake genome project is organized
it's
as a
global network of networks
that
has a common goal of sequencing all
1.8 million
known eukaryotic species in a period of
10 years
so it's a pretty ambitious project
and
we
we published the manifesto
if you will on this project in 2018
in uh in pnas it's cited there
at the bottom
myself
gene robinson from the university of
illinois
john krass from the smithsonian are the
co-founders of this project and now this
project has grown
to
encompass more than 5000
scientists from around the world and i'm
going to talk about that
the project officially launched two
years ago in london at the welcome trust
and um and since then we have been
making uh
really steady progress on the on these
goals and i'm going to tell you about
what we've been able to accomplish
in the last couple of years
so
one of the goals i think you can all
relate to this slide
is to create a digital repository
of all eukaryotic
life on earth
which
we feel will be the foundation sort of
it's an infrastructure
project if you will for the future of
biology and the future of the bioeconomy
global bio global bioeconomy
and so the this digital repository uh of
annotated 1.8 million
annotated genomes is going to be
exascale in in terms of the data
storage requirements just for the
genomes alone
and most of the biocomputational tools
that we have available today for
comparative analysis at that scale
are either inadequate or they don't
exist
so we're going to discuss those some of
those problems and challenges at the end
later in the talk
okay so why do this why even think about
sequencing all eukaryotes well
this digital repository of life will
allow us to address many
fundamentally important questions in
biology
and we've heard
a smattering of those
from the speakers yesterday and today
from accurate phylogenies gaining a
comprehensive understanding of genome
evolution the origins of eukaryotic
species
speciation processes and understanding
all the way up to understanding the
composition and functioning of complete
ecosystems
this kind of knowledge will be essential
for synthetic biology of the future
and applications
of in adaptive agriculture in human
medicine
conservation biology and in mitigating
the effects of climate change
and so what is the earth bio genome
project how exactly is it organized and
and so as i mentioned uh earlier it's a
confederated international network of
networks there are now
43 member institutions 50 affiliated
projects that have signed on to the
memorandum of understanding more than 5
000 participants around the world
in 22 countries where the affiliated
projects are located but
there are participants in these
affiliated projects in more than 100
countries around about half the
countries in the world are already
participating so the earth biogenome
project is now a very large and diverse
and inclusive organization
that strives to be a model
for large-scale scientific
collaborations and providing equal
opportunities for all people everywhere
to participate
in this
in this endeavor
recently we added uh one project in the
last year the africa biogenome project
here i'll do it here that one alone has
22 different countries there was a nice
article in nature
just a couple of months ago about this
project
um the members of of the ebp are
committed to developing standards so you
see the glob global hub and spoke
uh model
on the outside are the centers that are
doing the sequencing and
analysis on the inside and the red
circles are
taxon specific communities and the
center is the coordinating body which is
the you know what we're calling the
earth biogenome project
and the secretariat for the earth
biogenome project resides at uc davis
and um and i chair the the working group
i have the honor and privilege of
representing all of these people
uh around the world
and it has been quite a ride
so far
and so i mentioned the the hub and spoke
model and the importance of standards
and
and in addition to the importance of
standards which i'll discuss in a moment
the project also has a
ethical legal and social issues
committee and a justice equity inclusion
diversity and inclusion group two
committees uh
that are uh that have created guidelines
and principles for us
uh that uh
that we have open access to all the data
that is produced
and all in compliance with
the
conventional biological diversity and
nagoya protocols around access and
benefit sharing
i say this because this is a
particularly difficult problem that we
face in this project and that's it's not
the sequencing and it's not the assembly
we have the technology actually to do
this today if we had enough money
uh the problem is acquiring the samples
under the convention and ensuring
access to get access you have to
actually guarantee benefits it's
no access no benefits and of course
there's no benefits if you can't have
access and so it's one of the big
problems that we face
and
uh and again uh we want to do this in an
open inclusive way
uh
and and one of the ways that we're we're
doing this is building capacity uh
around the world in different places so
that um many different locations around
the world can contribute by
sequencing assembling and analyzing the
genomes from their own biodiversity
and so there's a lot of very serious
people some of these people's names
you'll recognize uh right away right
away federica de palma
is the chair of the international
science committee she was at the earlham
institute she was at the broad
for some time under with eric lander
she's now at
executive director of uh i think genome
british columbia
uh mara is a uc davis grad who's been at
the sanger for some time richard durbin
is the chair of our sequencing assembly
group you'd be known to most of you
probably paul felicek
from ebis chair of our annotation
subcommittee justin lin plateau
from upsla and and the broad is our
chair for our analysis uh subgroup ben
schaffeng way from bgi
who's
one of their
leaders at the china national gene bank
is the chair of the it and informatics
group
it's a very serious group and the
reports from each of these committees is
available on the ebp website so all of
the recommendations for
everything from sample collection and
processing and
sequencing and assembly
are all uh outlined in a series of
reports uh that you can
download read and download
now what about the strategy it's just
now we're gonna sequence uh 1.8 million
species how we going to do this
we're going to do it in three phases the
first phase will be to sequence a
representative species of all taxonomic
families there are about 9600 families
in all and that will be done uh to
reference quality
and that's shifting what that means but
we describe in detail what we mean by
reference quality uh in in our papers
right now a reference quality genome uh
for
for
your average eukaryote is probably
costing around seven or eight thousand
dollars uh and that the only thing we
need to do we've now reduced the process
from five steps and five different
technologies to two kind of goes to the
questions that were being brought up
yesterday about developing methodologies
we have people who worked on that
pipeline original pipeline well it's
down to two
technologies now uh you know hi-c
and uh long reads uh pac bio uh long
reads and uh that's really all you need
to get to reach the metrics that the
project has uh set
for uh assemblies
uh phase one ninety about ninety six
hundred phase two an increase in uh
fourteen fold uh output uh on a daily
basis
uh we've gotta get to uh in four years
to do about 119 000 genomes
these numbers depend on whose taxonomy
you use taxonomy is a very in exact
thing they're different taxonomies the
number in parenthesis is ncbi so ncbi
has 119 000
genera
and uh and 1.5 million species in the
out years uh
the last few years of the project if we
are successful
and
um this
i'll tell talk about what it will cost
that's the phylogenomic wave strategy
just to simply collect
go through first family than gender and
species but the reality is that people
are getting money to do different parts
of these projects some that are involved
in conservation work
others that are involved in ecosystem
work and so a second strategy which we
call the google life strategy deals with
location sampling
uh we're sampling all species in a
particular geographical area such as
biodiversity hot spots
there's a long-term ecological
uh monitoring program that are funded by
the nsf for example wythum woods which
is
very close to oxford
and was purchased actually by oxford's
been under continuous uh evaluation
since the 1940s for example they have
over 500
animals be 800
moths for example 500 plants and so on
and they really know a lot
about these
about these
locations and so the idea would be to
sequence everything darwin tree of life
project which is run out of the sanger
has
the goal of sequencing all biodiversity
in the uk and ireland that's about 62
000 species in all and they have funding
from the welcome trust and have begun uh
really working through their pilot phase
now and
it's coming along uh they're the major
contributor right now to uh to genomes
and all of this you know for all of you
models you know you can model at the
cell level or you can model at the
uh at the ecosystem level um you know
the idea is if you're looking at
ecosystems is to build models that can
produce a multi-dimensional and dynamic
view of how
populations have change
or species can can can change in
response to changes in environmental
conditions such as
climate change
and all of this can be done and the
numbers actually have gotten better over
time but the original estimates that all
this
uh would would cost about 4.7 billion
dollars
that was of a couple of years ago and if
you convert the money that was spent on
the human genome project the off-sited
numbers three billion dollars right to
sequence the human genome
in 2003 you can sequence all of
eukaryotic life on earth today for less
than the cost that it was for the human
genome
and if you
try and do the benefits you know you
look there depending on the reports
anywhere from 360 billion a year to a
trillion
and return on investment that's just for
one genome the human genome uh and uh
and today uh with with what we're facing
in climate change
for example
bioenergy production
agriculture adaptation of our important
agricultural species
of crops and animals
you know the return on investment is
likely to really be much higher and
biologists don't think in these terms
you know you think of your little r01 or
your nsf grant and such and you're very
happy but you know we're on a campus
where big science was practically
invented here you know
and uh if you look at the cost for
example uh the cost of the the web
telescope that was just put up right
took 20 years and the cost was 10
billion dollars
okay
and uh i'm not here to diss my
colleagues up on the hill or anything
but i say you know the value what is the
comparative value
you know of sequencing all of life on
earth versus you know
uh looking out in the heavens
understanding the origins of the
universe i mean there's just so much
that we're going to be gaining in terms
of knowledge and in terms of benefit
from doing this that it's kind of a
no-brainer it's just that we don't have
the kind of political power that the
physicists have now our colleagues in
the
physical sciences have but we're we're
getting there we're making uh inroads
and it's going to be
uh very interesting to see how this um
plays out but it's 4.7 billion over the
entire world you know it's not a lot of
money over 10 years or 15 years or
however long it takes it's going to get
done eventually and
that's what's um that's what's important
it's who's going to play the major role
in leading it that is
up for grabs i guess
and so uh what progress has been made um
so far i'll try and run through this
pretty quickly uh because of time issues
um this is the world status these are we
have a great team at the sanger
institute called the goat team and the
go team has created a fantastic
tool for
collecting metadata on all of the
assemblies
and we have very nice ways of producing
summary charts these are available on
the earth by a genome project website
this is everyone not just the earth by a
genome project participants but this is
the current status and i'll just point
to this number
right down here
which is
you know everything we know
right now in terms of you know what
we've been able to
derive from genome biology is from you
know less than one percent of known
eukaryotic life and what's unknown is
probably 10 times
of what we know
okay so
that's it that's what's what's known
even at the phylum level you know
depending on whose taxonomy you use 67
at ncbi not a single representative
species from all known phylum and part
of that is because some of the phyla are
you know their mind if they're single
cell eukaryotes you can't do assemblies
yet very well with single cell
organisms that can't be cultured
and so
part of the challenge i really love
sundas's talk because another great
application will be doing kind of
assemblies on these single cell
eukaryotes mixing short read data maybe
with high c data and getting a
reasonable approximation of what the
chromosome organization structure might
be
so
this is what ebp has has been able to do
of these totals so far in a very short
period of time and we're really focusing
remember at the family level which is
here
uh and uh and so you know with the
family level ebp is starting to make a
major contribution but as i'll show you
in a moment
it's really the quality of these genomes
here's all different qualities from
kante highly fragmented with hundreds of
thousands of contigs all the way to
telomere telomere genomes are included
here but those are not going to be what
we want we we we don't we want to have a
reference quality genome for at least at
the family level if not
um
for each species
uh i mentioned the go team i'll have to
go quickly here there are many different
features of this goat
tool one is at the ordinal level you can
search and see
if an organism a
representative
species from any order has been
sequenced and
then there are the summary charts
and this summarizes the activity for ebp
progress you know we're starting to
double this is just the first six months
of this year the colors indicate the
green color
are
these chromosome scale
assemblies
most of which meet the ebp reference abp
standards the blue are scaffold
assemblies you can see we're really
switching into
chromosome scale assemblies now
and the numbers are growing very quickly
this is uh species and this is families
and
and so progress is being made but i
think our most important contributions
of the affiliated projects
across the world is in the production of
these really high quality genomes so if
you look at those that meet the standard
just take
a very simple set of metrics which would
be one uh a a a contig n50
of one megabase and scaffold n50 of 10
megabases and you just use that as a as
a simple metric for a high quality
genome the only 1
316 of those 10 000 genomes that were in
insdc databases there's only
1 000
1 300 of those that meet even this
criteria and of those uh 41
are from ebp-affiliated projects and i'm
telling you right now this is a big
underestimate because we have 50
projects but only 25 of the projects are
in the goat system two of the really big
projects one which is
not located not far from here at jgi on
fungi has a hundred families done at
reference quality
and then bgi's data is not yet
integrated in there either so these are
under estimates of the contribution of
ebp to these high quality reference
genomes if you look at the family level
already 56 for nearly 56 percent of the
genomes are coming from ebp-affiliated
projects which is uh of these really
high quality reference quality genomes
coming from ebp so that's really uh
really great um i'm going to have to
wrap this up in a couple of minutes
there
been lots of papers already the first 16
genomes in
2021 uh look and most of the problems
that were looked at were very very
specific there were a series of uh 10
papers here a couple related to
conservation
another one of the affiliated projects
is zoonomia katie's uh involved in this
project
it's headed by eleanor carlson and
justin lin plateau
they have a series of
ten papers uh i guess we have a series
of ten papers coming out in science in
the next couple of months all the
revisions are being returned on the
actual uh really uh actual science
involved with this first set this what
they call the marker paper and uh and
it's a it's a really exciting group of
papers one is you know the applications
around conservation even individual
genomes can be very useful in predicting
threatened species based on runs of
homozygosity and overall heterozygosity
and
well i went the wrong way here and
again this is a project that katie was
involved in and one of her former
students kathleen keogh graham used this
happened during the pandemic
okay and i was in the shower one morning
saying how could we use to have to do
something to help solve this problem so
i
i said why don't we look at at ace two
uh and it so happened that there you
know the ace two is the is the receptor
for sarsko v
two
and there happened to be four hundred
and ten vertebrate species with uh ace2
receptors in the
database
and um well i don't have a lot of time
to go through this because we looked at
you know
regions of the molecule that had
undergone accelerated evolution and
selection and developed an index based
on similarity to the contact residues at
uh for for the spike protein and we were
able to make predictions about which
species uh might be susceptible sort of
a first pass very low-tech
uh effort
to get at which species might be the
intermediate host an issue that's still
not resolved whether this virus jumped
directly from bats to humans or whether
it went through an intermediate species
or possibly was even engineered in a
laboratory none of these hypotheses have
been uh completely excluded
but we made some predictions that have
people said oh no well you know here
very high turned out that all the
contact residues between humans and the
great apes were conserved every one of
the
the contact residues yep they were going
to be susceptible and sure enough within
a few weeks the first case at san diego
zoo of transmission to gorilla came up
and then this one went until last year
it said oh hi you know this is from a
completely different clade right these
are from these are laura's aetherians
these are you are conor guys and then
you know white deer this was one of the
highest
in the high category in terms of its
potential risk for binding for of the
spike protein and of course you know the
story white-tailed deer major
reservoir we didn't get them all right
but for a first pass it was really uh
showed the tremendous utility of having
uh these kinds of data i did want to
spend a lot of time talking about this
but um i don't have that much time
this these this work that we've been
doing for more
almost 20 years now on ancestral
reconstruction
uh has really been enabled by having
these reference quality genomes and
we've been very interested in what the
karyotype and genome organization was of
the ancestral mammal and what the role
of chromosome rearrangements uh really
is in speciation adaptation in the
development of disease as i mentioned we
started this nearly 20 years ago big
collaborative studies i talked about
modeling good behavior for
collaborations this was a great one
started between my lab and steve
o'brien's lab uh when bill murphy was
still postdoc there in my former postdoc
dennis larkin and graduate students
annalee everett's vanderwin this was a
time when there were only the human
mouse and rat was sequenced then we had
to figure out how to use maps
to uh to reconstruct ancestral genomes
using the algorithms that were developed
by pablo pebsner and glen tesla real
interdisciplinary collaboration and
these college regions represent
ancestral fragments that are overlaid
onto the human genome well this new
study now we've got a representative
from every mammalian order each of the
mammalian orders
sorry
and um
most of those are very high quality the
minimum uh n50 scaffold n50 is 14
megabases 13 of these assemblies
chromosome level 24 out of the 27 orders
of mammals
and
and with with two out group species and
we use this algorithm called the
scrambler which was developed with gen
ma we shared a postdoc when he was at uh
illinois j boom kim
and we used some of gian's
algorithms that we developed earlier for
doing reference assisted chromosome
assembly to de-scramble this is to to be
able to reconstruct the ancestor from
the synthetic fragments that we could
identify in excellent genomes so this is
kind of how the scrambler works
we can talk about it uses pairwise
alignment lassie alignments identifies
synthetic fragments between the
reference genome and the excellent
genomes you're comparing it to and then
uses phylogenetic information
as well as out group information
to determine what uh it's a
probabilistic model what the likely
adjacencies are between the syntenic
fragments
in the ancestor and then it uses a
greedy algorithm to to sort of order and
rank these and pull these out
and that's kind of how d scrambler works
and this is what we've been able to to
do now this is just the lineage leading
to human these are eight
different ancestors so these complete
reconstruction of the mammalian ancestor
at very high resolution
and all the steps inversions fissions
fusions from each step from the
ancestral mammal to the therian the
euthyry and the boreal theory and all
the way to human but we also did three
independent reconstructions to look for
biases using a reference from three
different lineages
and so the
eukaryotic genome the uh mammalian
genomes that we see today are just
really a mosaic of 2557
syntenic fragments that are about 800 kb
in size and these are the building
blocks are just switched in order these
are the building blocks of all
all genomes i'll have to skip this as
fascinating uh about how this
reconstruction relates to the
reconstructed amniote and the
reconstructed aids but several these
chromosomes nine of the chromosomes
actually
are uh equivalent one-to-one equivalence
of of chicken chromosomes
in the ancestral mammal separated by 130
million years of evolution we can see
conserved segments over 318 million
years
of amniote evolution
and within those segments say well why
are they conserved well we have
conserved functions uh you know this is
uh what you get when you do a go
analysis and you see these conserved
blocks have
enrichment for genes that are related to
development
and it makes a lot of sense you don't
break these blocks if you do break them
you're basically breaking the body plan
the normal development of these
organisms whereas the break point
regions between the blocks are highly
dynamic
have lots of novel genes zinc finger
proteins other rapidly evolving genes
related to sensory reception in the
environment so i have like a minute
and we have a story about tads which i'd
love to tell you but i don't have time
and
overall
chromatin architecture
that we showed in a paper just this year
postdoc my lab
can serve for 54 million years you can
look at these high c maps and even
though say the dingo and the puma these
are you know this is the fila day the
canada day and the ursa day here you
have two fissions that broke this
ancestral chromosome that you find in
cats into three different chromosomes
but the high c maps are identical and
eigenvectors this is what you get if you
can standardize all done and from the
same tissue all done from lymphocytes
and all done in the same lab eris
lieberman's lab this is all from dna zoo
and so we've been able to show that
chromatin structure is also
highly conserved and um i'll just end uh
like i said i had a feeling i'd run out
of time here that there are numerous
computational challenges we can discuss
these if we have time we've got to go
from 9 300 genomes
to
rather nine genomes a day which we've
basically achieved the capacity for in
the world in phase 2 to 123 genomes a
day and eventually to 1200 a day if
we're gonna do this in a few years so
huge technical and computational
challenges the computational challenges
are bolded here and have been mentioned
by several people already uh
tandy talked uh about resolving
phylogenetic relationships this is the
biggest problem uh that we face uh which
is doing whole genome alignments at
scale uh and annotation at scale that
was mentioned also
yesterday by anna i believe
and um and and of course uh the analysis
tools if you're interested in this
there's ten papers published in a
special issue in pnas just earlier in
the year
uh that
that's the cover and i just wanted to
thank my co-chairs john and jean
and the other committee chairs uh hank
greeley here at stanford who's chair of
the lc committee melissa who's at george
washington university i mentioned
federica before sadie and marcella
sadie's at rockefeller marcellus at
sanger and nicolette
and the folks from my lab two recent
post-docs
uh in the lab and chromosome evolution
working group zoonomia consortium and
all these folks these are really big
collaborations with a lot of people
spending uh a lot of time on uh working
together on important problems i'll just
close by saying one problem you know
what practical problem you know with
genome reconstruction uh solve and so it
was very interesting joanna just took a
job at colossal you know
so colossal is george church's company
he's involved in the extinction and of
course they realized that hey we're
going to de-extinct species maybe it
would be a good idea to understand what
the reconstructed genome might have
looked like before we tried to
de-extinct it so she actually got a
really interesting job
so thanks a lot i'm sorry i ran a couple
two minutes over here and we don't have
time for questions i guess but i'm going
to be here
maybe one or two okay thanks a lot folks
[Applause]
that's what you get when you try to give
three seminars in one
and it's a great time
i just had a quick question about
uh how well the assemblies like reflect
the actual raw reads so for example if
you remap how what is your remapping
fraction
so um
the assemblies are based you know
today's assemblies are based on you know
mostly a single individual and long
reads and the scaffolding is done uh
with high c
and uh in addition to the
to the scaffolding we also have you know
q
v is part of that so we use qv40
the assemblies that we're producing now
are haplotype they're all phased
assemblies one of those is some so it's
like two assemblies per individual one
of the assemblies is uh
is um
usually very good and the other one is
not that great
and they're all filtered so if you're
saying what are the contaminants how
that might if that's what what your
question is uh there are uh
decontamination
uh pipe decontamination is part of the
current pipeline so we take out you know
we found sequences from plants and
mammal species all kinds of
bad contamination issues and that's now
taken care of in the pipeline
so i think uh something like 90
we have to have at least 95 of the reads
mapping back
to the assembly or something like that
it's pretty high
you know the the yeah
is that yeah okay other questions
you have a minute maybe not yeah
sure
[Applause]